I'm Peter Russell I teach at UCLA and
Pepperdine and I'm here to talk today to
you about three amazing stories and I'm
gonna break down each one of them and
tell you what's great about it and the
first one I'm gonna start out with is a
great new television show in fact at one
Emmy of the best drama last year it's
called mr. robot and I'm really proud
one of my students has been in it just
really intimately involved in this story
from the beginning and I'm really proud
of him and I also want to talk about why
mr. robot as a television show has done
so well so when we look at a show a
television show it's very different from
a film in a lot of ways first of all we
need a hook that's gonna bring people
back for 100 episodes at least maybe 150
I have a manager he says Peter we got to
get 200 EPS whoever you're working with
we need to get 200 EPS because that's
when the big payoff comes but a hook in
television is different than a movie
it's what's gonna bring you back to the
story for episode after episode so what
is that in mr. robot
well the hook and mr. robot really is
this cyber vigilant a fighting against
these huge villains I mean if you have
credit card debt or if you have a school
debt then these villains are people you
can hate and part of the reason mr.
robots done so well with the young
demographic that it has is that so many
students and I have them at UCO and
Pepperdine they're in debt they're in
debt $100,000 or $200,000 and it's a
debt you can't get rid of you can't get
you can get rid of credit card debt you
cannot get rid of school debt so the
hook here for that audience and it's why
mr. robot is partly so popular is that
it's identifying the villain as a
villain that these people can hate and
that's going to bring them back for many
many episodes now what's the world here
it's the high tech world it's out of the
matrix and I often say in television if
you want to create a good original TV
show and I urge that you do because the
market now is roaring we've never had a
better time to teach to buy television
to sell television story we've gone from
250 to nearly 5
500 scripted shows in television in
America in the last five years
it is a boom so you want to have a movie
idea that you love and you want to twist
it slightly that's what mr. robot does
it twists the genre of The Matrix and it
makes it more modern
it's the cyber vigilante who is fighting
back against the system fighting back
against this incredible enemy so what's
the setting well it's New York that's
perhaps not its most important thing
it's most important attraction the theme
here is you can fight against the
biggest enemies in the world they are in
this case the finance company that run
the world the tone here is very real and
the tone is important in a television
show because if it's real you want to
make sure the show gives you real
genuine inside information and in mr.
robot that's what you get you get all
this great technology you really
understand how the internet works it
isn't just that horrible cliche in a
movie where somebody just goes oh we're
in and then that's the last you hear of
the computer technology it's all about
the computer technology it's very real
the character situation in a television
show needs to be one where it is a
permanent dilemma it's not resolvable in
one episode that's really important and
it's different from movies for instance
in Ashok I'd like Buffy the Vampire
Slayer which was a great show by Josh
Whedon Buffy's permanent dilemma is that
she is a she wants to just be a
cheerleader happy at a high school but
she has to kill vampires every week that
dilemma is never resolved when you have
a bad television show they don't do that
they simply give you a character that
you can resolve within a few episodes
it's no fun the permanent dilemma here
is that our hero is insane and he's also
never really going to be able to get
away from computers and from the
internet that's the way he fights the
villain but it's also the way that keeps
him alienated from the real world so we
have a fantastic permanent dilemma in
this show
we also have usually in a television
show a guy or a girl with a superpower
who is misusing that superpower at the
beginning of the pilot in Jessica Jones
she's misusing her superpower in even a
show like Mad Men Don Draper's misusing
his seductive ability to tell stories to
seduce women and to ruin families in
Breaking Bad we have a chemical genius
who is misusing his super power at the
beginning of the pilot he's not using
his chemical genius to do anything by
the end of the pilot he's using it for
malevolent purposes but he is using it
and so we also need characters who
fascinate and surprises so mr. robot has
all of this so what brings you back
every week to mr. robot is the same
thing that wrecks her back to man in the
high castle to making a murderer -
orange is the new black by the way what
is the big hook in orange is the new
black it's a great show done by a great
female showrunner the question that
brings you back is will Piper
ever figure out her sexuality and make
it out of prison and that's a permanent
dilemma because she never does she keeps
going back from men to women to men to
women and we want to watch and see if
she resolves that she never will most
great TV stories have this story
question at their Center and you need
that - what's the question in your
television show for Jessica Jones it's
will Jessica learn she can fight the
villain and win without losing her
ability to trust and love for Breaking
Bad it's how far as walter gonna break
bad the answer is insanely far so mr.
robot the question is will elliot be
able to take down the evil villain who
controls the world's entire banking
system a villain who enslaves nearly
everyone on the planet who has debt
that's a great question and we're gonna
see how by the way in Game of Thrones is
a very simple question who is gonna win
which family is going to win the the
throne and it takes eight years ten
years they say now for that question to
resolve itself okay so we always have
this in a great television show we
always do
the world here is not that great
breaking bad's is way better madman's is
the cool world of 60s sex in television
oranges new black what do you think that
is it's women in prison and it's very
sexy that's a great world mr. robots
world is the matrix but it's twisted
it's set in grunge hipster New York
Brooklyn New York and that also appeals
to its target audience right and the
venue matters too are you writing your
show for Network are you writing your
show for cable or are you writing your
show for Internet platform if you're
setting it for network it's gonna be
more tame but it also is ten times the
money if you're setting it for cable
you're making less money but you can be
far more free in what you show if you're
shutting it in the IP world you can show
anything right up to and including sex
and violence the content is twisted more
and more depending on the platform yes
now classic TV genres are just twists
that's what makes a modern television
show so take a television show you love
and twist it give it more sex give it
more violence or give it a appealing
villain that we can all hate mr. robot
is cable which means we can show nudity
we can show drug use we have a niche
audience right that means you can have
several plot storylines and your hero
can be darker than he might be in
network a lot darker and you can keep
him flawed and that's exactly what
Elliot is in mr. robot now remember in
television heroes don't heal they just
keep bleeding in a movie a hero will
heal by the end of the show
not so in television so if heroes don't
heal in television stories then why do
we want to watch them because remember
in university's story in my lectures I
was talking in movies about how he was a
healing and that change is what's
compelling about them well in television
if the heroes don't heal then why do we
want to watch them because they're gonna
surprise us with new character
revelations anybody remember that great
moment in The Sopranos when Janice and
Richie who are about to get married are
having a quiet evening at home and she's
cooking him dinner and they're both
irritated but it's just
another night suddenly Janice starts
irritating Richie suddenly where she
starts irritating Janice and suddenly
Richie hits her he back answer he's
never done that before now they're about
to get married that's a big surprise
we've never seen Richie do that before
it's not a change in his character it's
a revelation because we have a new
conflict she's irritated him and we also
can see that this is gonna be the way
it's gonna be for the rest of their
marriage he's setting her up to get hit
every night and then he sits down to
have his dinner and he says what are you
gonna do cry now and he starts eating
now
Janice is about to surprise us a lot
because Janice walks out of frame when
she comes back she's got a gun
he looks at her and he sneers Janice
I've got no time for this boom and she
kills him right there now that's not
Janice healing for God's sakes or really
even changing she's just showing us a
new facet of Janice a badass that is the
critical way television heroes give us
excitement and it's why we want to watch
television not to see them heal or even
get worse gray and Grey's Anatomy wanted
to get married I think in year 1 when
did she get married I think you're 9 and
now she's divorced again it isn't about
her healing as a character it's about
her surprising us
and in fact television is kind of more
like life than movies in this way and
it's part of what TV is so cool
television shows us surprise have you
ever known somebody for 15 years don't
they just get weirder and weirder the
better you know them finally they're so
weird you can barely take it well you're
just learning who they are
you're weird too by the way and you
don't reveal it to someone at the
beginning it's a process that's why
television story works so well and why
in a lot of ways it's the more
sophisticated form than movies so this
surprise is what we're gonna see in mr.
robot as well in Game of Thrones
surprise of eels character remember when
the Lannisters the brother and sister
are having sex at the end of that pilot
episode and suddenly a little stock boy
climbs up the tower and he sees them now
we didn't know Jamie Lannister was bad
until this moment
but Jaime Lannister goes to the window
takes the stock bye-bye the chest says
the things I do for love
and shoves him out the window surprise
Jaime Lannister is super evil and he's
also banging his sister these are the
surprises that make us love television
because they reveal character in such a
strong way so how is this gonna work in
a movie in a television show like mr.
robot no it's gonna work in a similar
way these conflicts are gonna be what we
see Elliott our hero and mr. robot go
through now Sam is male and by the way
Jenji Kohan is the fantastic showrunner
of orange is the new black gingy is one
of the most talented television writers
ever she can handle 10 or 11 or 12 story
lines in a single episode we're gonna
talk about what story lines are because
miss robot has four to handle 12 story
lines in a single episode is a sign of a
master she can do it
very few show runners can handle that
many storylines I really love her talent
for being able to do this now
let's take a look though tonight at mr.
robot now what does mr. robot let's just
logline mr. robot does everybody know
what a log line is because a log line in
television and a log line in movies is
very different in a movie log line
you're telling the story of how someone
changes the hero in a television you're
simply showing the heroes goals and his
obstacles in the way it's a very
different long line I urge you if you're
writing television to do what we call
breaking the a story log line over and
over again because it's literally
creating your story by asking yourself
what is my story and putting it in a
frame now here's mr. robots log line
when a lonely reclusive cyber security
engineer by day and a vigilante hacked
vigilante hacker by night hacker by
night is offered a chance by mysterious
anarchist named mr. robot to throw a
wrench into the hugely powerful
financial international corporation that
runs our world the engineer struggles
with his temptation to overthrow a
system he sees as deeply unfair
one that the elite used to control 99%
of humanity now if this were a movie he
would heal this wound he would overthrow
the corporation or they would smash him
in mystery fillers which this is you can
see the villain often wins but this is
television it is the struggle that's
gonna go on for a hundred and twenty
episodes and it will make it because
this is a great hit show that makes us
want to watch mr. robot his wound which
we're gonna see will bleed in every
episode it will look like it might get
better but it doesn't
now this show is created by Sam SML and
he is the creator and one of my former
students Korra Donna has been
instrumental in creating this show from
the beginning we're really proud of core
and this show is marvelous so let's take
a look at how it actually works we're
gonna break down this story entirely so
you can understand how you can write an
hour-long drama that's like this now
this is a serial multi story structure
that simply means that you have both an
overarching goal for the season but you
also have stories that get resolved
inside the episode this is the most
popular form of television why the
structure matters so much in television
it matters because people in television
have a short attention span and you need
to give them many different story plots
because they're also arguing with their
girlfriend they're also looking at their
cell phone their dog wants to get out
and they're also in a bed that they're
uncomfortable in and they're probably
emailing somebody right all of that's
happening when you watch television it's
not true in a movie theater now shows
like Mad Men Sopranos Game of Thrones
they all have an ongoing storyline over
the course of the entire run but they
also have multi multiple mini stories in
each episode now the a story is the main
story of the week that follows the
characters dilemma the hero's dilemma
the BCD stories in television also have
something to do with the main hero but
they're different stories and they
alternate in a very particular way and
it doesn't matter who you are as a
creator you will always alternate your
structure in this general way Soderbergh
Cronenberg even David Lynch he's
probably dragon kicking and screaming
but he follows this form as
well if you don't follow it great I'm
happy I love that you're gonna break
these rules but you have to show me that
the story's gonna work if you want to be
the first to break this pattern I'm with
you but the pattern to be broken has to
be broken in a way I've never seen let's
try it next time we do a console now
here are the four storylines in mr.
robot can the hero Elliott stopped the
big villains the bank can he find them
and stop them he has to find them that's
Creed this is a mystery thriller can
Elliott and his best girl who's not his
sexual romantic partner can they bond
and help each other heal that's the B
story line C is will helia team up with
his mentor in this story mr. robot to
bring down the corrupt system and the
fourth the D storyline is will Elliott
save his shrink from her horrible
boyfriend
each of these storylines get asked in
the cold open in the first act and they
get answered by the end of the fourth
act they all get wrapped up and that is
critical every one of your storylines in
television must be wrapped up and
answered yes or no by the end of the
show so how does this four story line
work in mr. robot okay so mr. robot and
we already know what the log line is
let's ask yourself what's the hook well
we already said we want to see this
cyber vigilante went against the matrix
okay we want to see whether we can do it
and in the cold open of this story now I
suggest you guys get the opening pilot
episode of mr. robot up with you on your
screen and watch this with me so you'll
understand the structure really well or
get the script either one I can't show
it to you here for copyright reasons but
I urge you to go through it with me and
by the way guys I really urge you to get
the script and watch it as you watch the
episode it's amazing what you learn when
you do that now this is a mystery
thriller now a few years ago all I did
was movies I didn't do television at all
now 80% of my business is television
maybe 90 I learned a lot about movie
genre and I learned a lot about mystery
thrillers I have a book coming out on it
mystery thrillers in movies I thought oh
god when television begins such a big
deal I thought am I even gonna work can
I take what I've learned in movies and
put them in television too
great answer is yes everything I've
learned about movies work in television
there's only two big differences we
already mentioned heroes don't change
people don't change and you can tell a
lot more than show those are the two
critical differences between movies and
TV everything else is the same
all the genre patterns I'm gonna show
you work in television just as they do
in movies and mr. Rawat is a mystery
thriller what does that mean one of the
reasons one of the things that means is
that the villain is hidden and he's not
a small villain he's a huge villain he
is the most malevolent villain you could
ever imagine
but he's hidden at the beginning of the
story so when we open mr. robot how do
we open it Eliot says in a vo there is a
conspiracy bigger than all of us it's a
group of people that we don't know that
one percent against the ninety-nine and
as he tells us this we see the shadowy
mostly probably white men standing
around behind a boardroom and we don't
see their faces why because I remember a
mr. pillar whether it's Chinatown LA
Confidential salt any of these movies
the hit that real villain is hidden at
the beginning of the story we don't see
him but everything happens because of
him there's a powerful group of people
out there and they run the world yes
they're invisible now mystery thrillers
are very hot in television right now I
urge you to think about making one man
on the high castle which is a brilliant
adaptation of a Philip dick story
excellent adaptation so it's a
hallucination they're completely
changing it Jessica Jones mr. robot
mystery thrillers many coming I'm
working on several right now so just
let's look at what a mystery thriller
means mystery thrillers about hidden
evil whether it's Maltese Falcon or
inception or LA Confidential or salt
thrillers are not it's not the same as a
thriller in a thriller the villain comes
out and you and you see the hero
battling him very fairly quickly you may
not know who he is but you see him
battling him but that's true in seven
but it's not true insult or inception
because in a mystery thriller there's
three levels of story plot okay stay
with me guys this is a little
complicated but you
need to know this because mr. robot has
them all and the reason they have them
is the mystery thriller audience wants
to be baffled you ever seen anybody who
loves to do crosswords they're looking
at the New York Times crossword puzzle
and what are they doing they're going oh
oh my god oh my god I don't think I can
solve it Oh Peter I don't think I can
solve it oh my god what is that that's
the adrenaline that comes from for you
looking at a puzzle not being able to
solve it then when they do solve one
what do they do they go oh they get a
kind of a dopamine high it's a kind of
an orgasm because they have it's now
solve the mystery that's all mystery
thriller does for you it poses a mystery
and then it lets you solve it okay not
my genre when I went to Inception I was
like what the hell's happening I'm gonna
go I'm gonna leave the theater but the
mystery thriller audience loves that
mystery now that means they crave a
complicated story so there's three
stories and mr. siller's there is the
distraction plot that is what you see
quickly in act one that looks like the
real crime that's going on in the story
but it's actually just a distraction the
second plot is the emotional change in
the hero that helps them solve the crime
and the third plot is the real crime
what's really going on that does not get
revealed till act five in the story now
it's hidden okay so in this story it's
the fact that this bank runs our world
this Bank controls all of us but that's
not what we see at the beginning of the
story okay what do we see we see a hero
with a core wound if you look at the
beginning of the story you'll see that
Elliot is sitting in a subway with his
hoodie on he's got hooded eyes he looks
like a crazy guy he's a great actor and
he is a crazy guy he's paranoid he
believes that the world's out to get him
and in fact he's mentally ill his core
wound is that he cannot cannot connect
to people that he is alone that he's
helpless that he is emotionally unable
to ever be with anybody and so what we
see in the cold open which simply means
the first five pages of the script the
first five minutes of the story we see
him on a subway we see him saying
there's all these crazy people out here
in there and there's there's conspiracy
that too
to damage us all and then we see him
suddenly say I should have gone to
Angela's birthday party why do we see
those two things because the B story
here is can Eliot bond to his friend
Angela and not feel alone so we're gonna
see the a and the B story in the cold
open you always do later we're gonna see
what those two aren't breaking bad the
cold open gives us those two storylines
and they're gonna alternate through the
entire rest of the hour pilot he says I
should have gone to Angela's birthday
party but I didn't because I cannot
connect to people guys if you want to
give us sympathy for your hero show his
core wound or her core wound immediately
show it in the first minute of the story
if you've ever done it in a note that
says your hero was in sympathetic it's
because you're not showing their core
wound what makes you like someone not
because they're rich or famous are
strong that doesn't want what makes you
like someone when they show you the
roamer ability when they show that they
are screw-ups just like you this is what
great stories do immediately and this is
what we get with with Elliot so remember
in the cold open we have the a and the B
story the a storyline here can le bring
the big villains to justice what's he
doing here in the cold opening if you
guys are following on please do please
be watching this while I give you this
lecture it's gonna be so much better for
you if you can I wish I could show it to
you um he's remember I told you eight
hero in a television pilot is often
misusing his super power at the
beginning of the show and Elliot is
misusing his super power to be going to
show how well he's working for a
corporation that actually helps the
villain that's a misuse what's his
superpower he's an amazing computer
hacker right but she's misusing it at
the beginning and in this a storyline in
the cold open he's also though and the
reason we love him so much is he's
bringing one villain to justice not the
big villain but a small villain a
pedophile in a coffee shop and as he
does this he brings all of his technical
knowledge to bear and he's busted this
pedophile who has a
ring of coffee shops but he's got this
this pedophile porn ring and he busts
him but as he says he does so he says
his core wound he tells the pedophile
you know what I sympathize with you I'm
different too here's his poor wound I
don't know how to talk to people
Eliot says my dad was the only one I
could talk to it gives us his core wound
it makes us empathize with this weird
weird God cuz we're all weird right we
want to know our heroes are weird and
story because it means they're real and
his dad died why it's very important a
corporation killed him poisoned him his
dad worked with pollution and then Eliot
says the corporation is fine
my dad is dead this is the bleeding
wound that's gonna tie right in with our
a storyline fighting a corporation that
has so much power that they can hurt
people and continue to be in violent
this is a beautiful way that SML brings
this story together now the pedophile
tries to pay him off but he won't Elliot
says I don't care about money I got
another surprise and then they bust him
and that's the end of the cold open now
guys we're not gonna have time today to
talk about the Forex structure in
television but it's important you know
what it is it's seven different beats
per act the a storyline has 15 to 16 of
these beats the B has seven to eight the
C has three to four and the D is why do
I talk about this if I'm not really
going to talk about it because you need
to look at my television lecture or
somebody else's television lecture to
make you understand that every act every
hour-long drama has this same structure
no matter how crazy you are and how much
you want to break the rules the reason
it's there is to entertain the audience
in a rhythm like a pop song has a bridge
chorus a verse even the craziest ones
right they all do because it entertains
the audience so we're not going to talk
about that all now but you need to
understand that's true and each beat has
a hero and
and a fight inside the beat a beat is
two or three minutes long it is a single
dramatic act and there's 28 of them in 8
hour long television show and in mr.
robot there is 2 beats in the cold open
one of the beats is this big fight
between Elliot and this pedophile and
it's resolved at the end of the beat
it's as if you ate 24 or 28 little
canapes as opposed to one giant entree
it entertains you now remember these
patterns are all to keep the audience
entertained so we've opened on the a and
the B and by the way if you're looking
at this and viewing it you'll see mr.
robot Christian Slater right there you
know on the subway at the beginning
he's the mentor he's a shape-shifter
which means are gonna talk about that in
a minute
mentors he'll give us car loans that's
what they're for and that's what he's
gonna start doing now in television they
don't heal completely but they heal a
little bit and remember we have three
pots and a mystery filler I know I'm
talking a lot about this I know it's
confusing you can watch this several
times the plot in a mystery thriller
that's really critical is that there's
an emotional change in the Gila
throughout the story that helps him
solve the crime that's the key and all
great mysteries fillers whether it's
movies or television so Elliott is in
the beginning of act 1 and we start with
our a storyline usually in act 1 le is
on that subway and the a story questions
can he beat the villains and we also see
mr. robot who says it's an exciting time
to be in the world today uh it's
Christian Slater we kind of see him out
of the corner i Rolo well who's that guy
and that's all we see of him now because
remember in a mystery thriller things
are hidden at first they only pop up a
little bit now Elliott tells us I'm only
a vigilante Hocker by day by night and
during the day I work for a company that
is actually evil interesting huh and we
see him go to his office and we see now
the B storyline come in because his
friend
Angela who he's not sleeping with but
has been friend since he's a childhood
it's arguing with their boss now this is
really important because Angela is a
girl in a man's world she's a woman in a
man's world and she's being condescended
to the boss is sexist towards her and
we're gonna see that that's critical in
this story and it's part of what makes
this story so appealing to 20-somethings
because so many women in the workplace
are experiencing just this right now and
it's also gonna make us like Elliot
because he's gonna help her but she's
gonna teach him how because he screws it
up at the beginning when we first see
her she's telling her boss that she can
handle the problem then the boss is
saying no you can't so what is our bee
story here remember it's can Elliot bond
with Angela if he can you'll have an
emotional change that will help them
solve the crime can by the way this is a
buddy relationship here Angela Elliot
and if you look at my lectures on
university story you'll see whether it's
a buddy or a love story usually one of
the two partners in this relationship is
teaching the other one how to be
confident and the other was teaching the
other one how to be caring these are
lakhs they have that form the chemical
reaction that we're gonna want to want
to watch whether it's the notebook or
Titanic or a cop buddy movie this is
usually the dynamic and in this story it
is as well
because Elliot lacks what do you think
caring he's got a little Asperger's and
Angela lacks confidence so when we first
see them we're seeing her try to justify
to the boss that she can handle the
situation and the boss shrugging it off
and saying you can't handle it now
suddenly we get what's coming up to be
inciting incident the boss says to
Elliot we were hacked again the company
we weak poor Ecore the big company the
evil villain the real villains in our
real crime
they were hacked last night someone
broke in Elliot's bosses freaked out
it's their biggest client a corporation
and Elliot is the guy who's gonna help
rescue that remember he's misusing his
super power he doesn't want to do it
he's working for a company that is
actually helping a villain so angela is
supposed to be in charge in this
situation but she's not cuz she's a
woman she's shoved aside she lacks
confidence and she lets them do it to
her what's her core wound cuz that's
important to her core wound is she's not
powerful she's letting men tell her
she's not powerful she's going to have a
change in this story too
guys this is a brilliant story SML is a
brilliant creator so much is going on
here when you watch this story you will
see angela lacks the confidence she can
do this job she wants Elliot now the
next thing we see is her say to him she
takes him aside hey Elliot why didn't
you come to my party last night
guys what storyline is that that's the B
storyline can Elliot bond with Angela
emotionally now angela is reflecting to
him as a good buddy what he needs to
learn Elliot you must bond emotionally
with people and notice what Elliot says
to her uh yeah I'm sorry I couldn't make
it and she says you promised me you
would try she's trying to help him do
what learn to care this is a classic
relationship dynamic now we go to the
deep lot which often happens on the
first act and if you want to break down
of all these act structures go to my
televisions lecture on university of
story I have all of this broken down and
it's critical that you understand this
and I don't understand why most people
don't do this in their books but it's
why I do it there's another plot here
the D plot will Elliot save his shrink
from her evil con artist boyfriend now
we see that she's a psychologist but
here's what's interesting about Elliot
and any character when you first see a
character you have his wound
now what if you're wounded as a person
what do you know what's your first of
all ask yourself what's your biggest
wound okay
emotionally what's your biggest
embarrassment now what have you done to
compensate for that in your life okay
what do we do when we have a core when
we compensate and we do it in bad ways
Jessica Jones in her show compensates by
having lots of random sex she's been
mind raped by the villain and so as a
consequence she can't connect to other
people emotionally so she has a lot of
mindless sex yes in this show
Elliot's core wound is I'm alone and
powerless so he lies he's a liar this is
important because when you create a
character with a core wound you want at
least three or four attributes they have
that are not good but they're
compensations for their wound there are
things we wish we didn't do but because
we're wounded we do bad things he lies
so in the deep lot when he's dealing
with his shrink he lies to his shrink
his shrink knows that he's not telling
the truth but she asked him why do you
feel so alienated Eliot now Eliot in his
head is telling her why watch the show
but he's actually not saying a word
but as he's talking in his head the
audience is loving what he's saying
because why does he say he's the way he
is he says and this is what we always do
when we compensate for a wound you know
why I'm this way because the world is
let me tell you how the world is
screwing our heroes are all screwy our
heroes are Donald Trump our heroes are
Bill Cosby our heroes are people like
that that lie they're hypocrites that
are horrible our heroes and our and our
world is full of people who lie and also
we have we have crappy movies we
entertain ourselves we dope ourselves we
get into debt he doesn't actually say
any of this to her what he says to her
is I'm fine so we're staying the
disconnect and we're seeing what Elliot
needs to heal and we're seeing why
Elliot is wounded he does understand
with her why he likes her which is that
she's warm
this is why he's there at all now she
asked him did you go to Angela's
birthday party remember our B story plot
can you connect emotionally people
that's what the shrink is there to help
him try to do this is critical in this
story remember in the mystery thriller
it is the emotional change of the hero
that helps him solve the crime if he
does not connect emotionally Elliott
will never ever succeed in this pilot
okay and remember this is also a beat
and in a beat we have a protagonist and
an antagonist and a fight and the fight
in this scene is Elliott will you tell
the truth Elliott's actually antagonist
in the speed and Elliott says yeah I
will but he doesn't and they fight and
he finally wins and that's the climax of
that little beat each beat has that
conflict right so let's go back to the a
story when he gets back to his office we
now meet finally both the distraction
villain and the real villain here they
come a corporation comes to Elliott's
company because they're so angry they've
been hacked and we meet who we think is
the villain Terry Colby this old white
guy with a tie and our there's a
distraction pot and a real crime pot we
also in this scene are going to meet the
real villain but he's not who we think
Terry Colby is the guy we think as a
villain and so by the way is Elliott
because Elliott is a pawn in a mystery
thriller the hero is a pawn of the
villain he is a very unsuccessful guy
who was being used by the real villain
to evil ends and that's true for Elliott
but then at the very end of his scene
notice who Elliott meets along with the
old fat white guy is this young sleek
beautiful dude in a perfect suit
his name is tyrell wellick and as he
goes by Elie and he says hey Elliott how
you doing it ah i'm tyrell wellick hey
man I'm just about your age I noticed
you're using a certain kind of software
I used to do that when I was
oh yeah I was a hacker anyway it's great
to meet you I'll talk to you later
well not know that until the end of our
story just did you don't know in LA
Confidential who the real villain is
till the end of the story just as you
don't know insult who the real villain
is till the end of the story always true
in a mystery filler now act 2 opens with
our a storyline and what is Elliott
saying he's saying I can't why can't I
save the world
now we're gonna see explicitly why he's
wounded not all stories do this but I
urged you to do it if you can because if
you can show the wound happening to your
hero you will have gobs of sympathy for
him what a normal people do when they
get sad this is what Elliott asks will
they reach out to other people but I
can't do that and we suddenly flash on
the screen his mother and him when he
was four tied to a high chair and her
beating him explicit the core wound this
is why he cannot connect this is the
core wound in action right and don't
think you can ever get away from this
you can't I don't care if you're writing
sci-fi you need to show this core wound
and it's bleeding this is true for Don
Draper and madmen this is true for
Walter White this is true for Tyrion
Lannister in Game of Thrones what do you
think his core wound is by the way right
daddy didn't love me well look what he's
gonna be doing he kills his dad in a
crossbow his deaths in the toilet and
many other terrible things because of
his core wound Rustin Marty and true
detective have core wounds that are
critical to enjoying the story 2nd
season of True detective not so much so
we see that Elliott was hurt by someone
who was supposed to be his strongest
caretaker and then that happens to us it
screws us up terribly I'm alone he's
thinking I'm powerless it also
underlines all four of our storylines
the beasts toiling really connect to
Angela No
so we see
using what here comes another
compensation for his core wound he not
only lies what else do we do when we're
bleeding we do other things he uses
morphine he blanks out his pain with
drugs and we see him using morphine now
what else do we see he uses sex as a way
of escaping a bad reflector character
comes in now reflective characters are
just characters that reflects something
that hero should learn or what he
shouldn't learn this bad reflector is
his dealer she's also a girl and she
also tempts him to do ecstasy with her
and he doesn't want to do it but he does
it he is moving away from healing and
all aspects we're getting into the
second acts now guys we don't have time
tonight to talk about another structural
issue called the BM MOC structure which
is but you should know there are five
times in a television our pilot when the
hero is asked to heal a little bit these
are five dramatic climaxes in every
great television story if your story
doesn't have them the rhythms not going
to be there there's a BMOC pattern in
movies it's more complicated in
television again I go into this in my
foundations lecture on university of
story
it's a critical pattern but it's it's
for another lecture but he is moving
away from healing he's moving away from
connecting in every aspect of his life
right now okay so we have a little bit
more of a deep pot but then we get
Angela at the office saying Elliot come
back I need you something terrible has
happened this is the inciting incident
because what is it
it's our B story can Elliott help Angela
really connect to her emotionally she
says I need your help when he gets there
guess what's happened there is a huge
attack on the evil corporation and
remember Elliot's company is supposed to
keep them safe and it's an attacker
already there can't solve angela can't
solve they need Elliot's superpower
Elliot's boss comes in he brushes Angela
aside again remember she's being treated
like a woman who knows nothing
now we see if you're watching the
episode that Elliott gives us all these
cool I call it the weed of the story
because it's a pleasure for you he tells
us this isn't just a DDoS attack this is
a TOI attack it's a boot sequence attack
it's a rootkit all of these things let
us know that this story really is not
giving us bull it's telling us the truth
about this world and we're excited when
you tell the truth about a world we want
to see that when you research your story
guys don't set a story in Pakistan and
you being a CIA agent if you've never
been to Pakistan if you're not a CIA
agent I'm gonna know it's horribly
stupid before two minutes are up
Sam has great technical support for this
show anyway so they go down to the
server farm with great ticking clocks
with great sequences Elliott actually
solves the issue and he gets the attack
isolated the hacker he stops but guess
what else happens he sees a message
embedded inside that malware inside that
virus that says leave me here
this is his mentor this is mr. robot
this is his awakening and his call and
we have the C storyline finally well
Elliott team up with mr. robot to break
down the system and Elliott has a
dilemma because as a employee he's there
to get rid of this to root this out but
he decides to leave the message there
because he wants to meet mr. robot and
he says I don't want to leave it I
wanted to stay
Willie team up with mr. robot the
question is answered right in the
beginning maybe now act 2 ends with our
first M point which is remember our BM
MOC story question is is he going to
break down the villain is he gonna team
up with mr. robot to break down the
villain and in the end of our act we see
mr. robot in him on a subway and mr.
watt says to him I want to break you out
of your present I want you to work for
me
and in order for him to do that though
we have a great ticking clock watch the
show mr. robot gets off the subway and
says if you want to work with me you're
gonna boil me if you don't just stay
where you are and Elliott sits and sits
and sits and as the doors begin to close
loop he goes through them and he is
gonna be with mr. robot Willie hook up
with mr. robot that's the c-store line
question and it looks like he is he now
goes of mr. robot to Coney Island to the
robots lair and he is going to see that
this what they're all doing there what
all the hackers are doing there is they
are fighting against the big corporation
they're figuring out a way to beat them
but he leaves them not knowing for sure
if he's gonna join them or not
and when he gets back to his apartment
we get back to the be story line because
who was waiting for him Angela will he
connect with Angela caring and
confidence she says to him I'm glad
you're here do you want to go in and get
high and watch Netflix which we all know
is a bit of a pseudonym she wants to
hook up with him will he he says yes but
when they get inside
Helly it's drug dealer and friend with
benefits is there so Angela and Elliot
do not connect this is critical she
leaves now he decides to go back to see
mr. robot again and we're back to the C
storyline will he hook up with mr. robot
and here's when mr. robot poses an
irresistible question to Elliot
what if you could take down the one
conglomerate that is the most evil in
the world what if I told you that this
conglomerate is something that controls
all of us through our debt anything else
and mr. robot says if you get together
with me Elliot we can wipe out the
biggest villain in the world now Elliot
doesn't want to commit now mr. robot
says here here's a here's a data file
put it in the system and it will frame
Terry Colby
we think and he thinks is the real
villain and get rid of him he'll be
thrown out of the e corporation Ellie
says but he's just one guy mr. robot
says that's how we start you don't do
this all at once so the invitation has
been given will Elliott stop the big
villains will he team up with mr. robot
will he
mr. uber says if you do this you will
have set in motion the largest
revolution in the history of the world
now how do we decide a question like
that with a montage because the hero
goes away says I don't know about this
we hear Neil Diamond's if you go away
play as we see him thinking as he walks
down the subway is he going to do this
will Elliott find and stop the real
villains our second endpoint we're at
the end of the third app it looks like
he's going to maybe do it we don't know
le it's thinking about it and we see him
go online and check
Angela's debt Angelo's two hundred
thousand dollars in student debt really
helped her he could but guess what
Elliott decides not to do it this is now
the fourth act we're headed for in the
fourth act both the low point for the
hero and also a high point of view it
all happens in act 4 the obstacle point
which is the moment when he seems to
fail and the climax when he seems
finally to succeed le decides not to
frame the villain so the next day he
goes back in and they meet and they meet
with the big fat apparent villain and he
says to them okay so did you find out
why we got hacked or not
so Elliott has decided not to take down
the apparent villain until the apparent
villain Terry Colby pulls this bonehead
move during the meeting and remember
they're at this meeting because they
want to find out who hacked them Colby
Terry Colby the apparent villain disses
Angela Angela remember is a in a sexist
world and her big problem is she doesn't
have the confidence to be able to stand
up to these guys
and Kolby starts talking to her and she
makes a critical mistake she gives him
the wrong date of when the incident took
place and you guys know if you have a
boss who doesn't like you they're always
looking for a reason to fire you yes and
when Angela makes this little mistake
which doesn't really mean much and the
great scheme of things Kolby suddenly
goes wait a minute you gave me the wrong
date this this attack didn't happen on
that day it happened the day before and
suddenly he's talking to Tyrell who
remembers a real villain saying and
Angela is literally thrown out of her
own meeting and the apparent villain the
old white guy says - Elliot our hero
you're the one who stopped the hack
we're gonna talk to you about it
subtext you're a guy you're a computer
guys she's just a girl
now remember Elliot was about to not
frame this old guy when he sees what she
did and what he did to Angela he changes
and remember it is the emotional change
in the hero that lets him solve the
crime in a mystery Spiller he defends
Angela in his heart he says screw you
too Kolby I am gonna frame you it's a
brilliant change right in the speech and
he takes the file that will frame Colby
and he says here it is now guys this is
what I mean by having the obstacle in
the climate's point in one act the
obstacle point comes in the middle of
act 4 but then the climax comes soon
after and the climax is when he says I
am gonna frame him he frames him and
then the story
answers the question will Elliot connect
with Angela also it answers the question
will Elliot fight the big guys but he
remember in a mystery thriller the real
villain is hidden so
when he does this nothing happens when
we open her next act he's just waiting
the FBI doesn't get it get it nobody
gets it nobody digs up the dirt on Colby
and for 19 days nobody busts Colby we
see him wrap up his shrink plot he hopes
his shrink uncover her rat boyfriend he
uses his super powers to find out the
boyfriends quadruple timing Elliot's
shrink and he helps her but we're gonna
wrap up the b2 and here's how we do it
for 19 days l8 Angele don't communicate
but when they do they do it this way
have you ever had a UH if you're a guy
if you ever had a girl tell you don't
condescend and try to help me in a
particular way because you're being
condescending as you do
Angela finally tells Elliot you know
what you stepped in and tried to help me
at that meeting I didn't watch to do it
that way
I want you to help me when I ask you for
it not in a way that undermines me this
is her having the confidence to tell
Elliot what she really wants and she's
asking Elliot to care enough about her
to do it her way and he does he's got
Asperger's but he still does and in this
moment in the story if this was a movie
they would clinch and kiss they both
want to do it but remember this is
television they are never gonna fall in
love or if they are it's gonna take 8
years so they simply stare at each other
with longing looks but we've answered
the b-story question Angela and Elliot
have connected emotionally that's and
she's developed confidence knowing how
to be her own person in a business
meeting and he's developed caring I care
enough about you to do it the way you
want she's teaching him how to care
about her don't ever stick up for me
that way again now since there's no
romance because it's TV we end on our a
storyline will Elliot find the real
villain and now as he walks out into
Times Square he sees on the big screen
Terry Colby arrested Terry Colby was
behind the
attack on his own company and Elliot
puts his hands up in the air and he goes
yes yes yes I've done it I've got it
I've Bank wished the real villain but
remember this is a mystery thriller and
in mystery thrillers the villains often
win this happens in Chinatown
this happens in even in a way in LA
Confidential this happens a lot and as
Elliot celebrating two bloomin and black
suits while the cops watch and do
nothing bustle Elliot into a limo and
they arrest him and they take him to the
same place we started this pilot and
remember where we started this pilot
there are people who control this world
and their shadow and we don't know who
they are and then at the beginning of
the movie of the television show we saw
them as shadowy figures and now what do
we see we're about to meet the real
villain the 1% of the 1% and this time
that shadow a group of people has a
light on them and it's Tyrell and he
says has one and the story has just
begun this guy's using all the patterns
of the mystery thriller and all the
patterns I've taught you right now this
is what's happening in television today
this is why television is so good